so we've been given a new look at love
and thunder in the form of a promotion
that marvel has done on tiktok let's
break it down so the promo begins with
it saying meet the characters of for
love and thunder we then see the man
himself the god of thunder in the new
footage of him here we see him still out
of shape and he's working out to get
back in shape we've seen in previous
trailers other footage of him also
working out so it's safe to say we'll
see some type of montage of him get him
back into shape next up we have valkyrie
as king of new asgard she's seen saying
a couple words as she then side eyes the
person she's speaking to under promotion
video they're just playing music so
we're unsure what she's saying here next
up we have natalie portman as mighty for
where we see her going to high-five
someone she's also seen having a
conversation whoever she is speaking to
but yet again we're unsure what she's
saying here next up we have new footage
of korg and he is seen getting shot in
the face as he collapses to the floor
and then raises his hand and a thumbs up
indicating that he is obviously okay now
judging by the interior of this location
it looks like it could be the interior
of the garden of the galaxy ship and to
end off this promotion video we have an
extended shot of four here which i'll
play for you guys now what a classic
forward
that's pretty much everything for this
video so if you did enjoy this breakdown
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching